à l'oratoire saint françois de sales la
messe est célébrée en la tête tous les
dimanches chaque semaine des centaines
de fidèles se réunissent dans cette
communauté catholique traditionaliste la
décision de l'état du missouri de
légiférer pour criminaliser l'avortement
fait l'unanimité tu es un enfant sans
défense c'est le on va dire le plus
grand crime pierre d'humains et vicaire
ici depuis quatre ans il s'est toujours
défini comme un pro vie et maintenant
ils partagent ces convictions avec les
jeunes de sa communauté mais cela va au
delà de la religion et ce n'est pas
parce que je suis catholique que je ne
tue pas
un athée ne tue pas non à un être humain
on ne tue pas un être humain est donc
l'un briand est un être humain donc on
ne tue pas l'embryon ici les familles
sont nombreuses
l'avortement n'est pas une option même
en cas de viol la question d'abord c'est
pourquoi il ya des viols il faut chaud
pourquoi les à des viols pourquoi elle
venait à ce manque de respect pour la
femme à quelques kilomètres de
l'oratoire on trouve la seule clinique
d'avortement de tout le missouri mais
depuis vendredi quiconque y pratiquer
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
s'expose à une peine de cinq à 15 ans de
prison c'est devenu un crime au même
titre que d'homicide volontaire choc
j'avais entendu que c'était quelque
chose qui
est en discussion mais j'ai jamais pensé
qu' ils prendraient les droits aux
femmes tania thomas s'habille tout me
sourit depuis plus de 25 ans mère de
deux filles elle craint que cela ne
s'arrête pas là donc le mariage entre
deux personnes du même sexe ou bien
les autres droits comme
la contraception la fille de tania et
doctorat en médecine et
elle sent que son avenir est menacé jade
a travaillé dans une clinique venons en
aide à des femmes victimes de violences
conjugales
cette décision aura un effet domino dit
elle prononcé
samedi pour des
violences conjugales la grossesse est
utilisé pour répéter des modèles et
garder les femmes prisonnières de ce
modèle de génération en génération
pierre d'humains crois plutôt que cette
décision aura un effet positif dans les
états qui suivront l'exemple du missouri
je pense qu'on va voir la différence
entre les états après quelques années on
les états qui vont interdire
l'avortement
et les gars qui vont continuer à
fortement et on va voir la différence
les états qui vont s'effondrer parce
qu'il n'y aura plus d'un il n'y a plus
de de tissu social par semaine et plus
d'enfants pour l'instant c'est le débat
qui menace le tissu social du missouri
ici valérie gamache radio canada c'est
louis